foreign
on a bank holiday I know what you're
thinking he's underpaid he's overworked
and they even drag him in on a bank
holiday but that's that's how you get to
the top commitment and dedication on
days when everybody else is having
barbecues and lying by the beach not me
oh no oh no it's coronation week I'd
like it or not the eyes of the world are
on the British Monarchy this will be an
historic State occasion to put it in
context think about this the procession
on Saturday will be twice as big as the
procession for the Queen's funeral three
times as big as the procession for the
Platinum Jubilee this will be the
biggest celebration of our monarchy and
British modern history since of course
the Queen's coronation back in 1953 But
ultimately it belongs to the British
people
the monarchy belongs to the British
but in trying to make precisely that
point the palace has begun this
momentous week with what looks to me
like a bit of a misstep and I'll tell
you why in a striking change to an
ancient ritual the watching public will
be invited to pay homage to King Charles
by reciting an oath of Allegiance
something normally reserved for
Aristocrats in Westminster Abbey it's
supposed to make the service inclusive a
people's coronation they say but instead
it's played into the hands of the
naysayers and Republicans bent on
souring this coronation scenes like this
up at Celtic feel like a kind of
inevitable response to being asked to
pay homage and bear allegiance to the
king
oh
everything
so much
[Applause]
well utterly Charming of course as ever
from Celtic fans but that's what they've
always been like towards our monarchy
and I have a similar view of Celtic fans
so all's fair and Love and War now
they've got mixed feelings obviously
about this they're not even mixed really
I've got mixed feelings too because our
King has earned Allegiance from us with
the longest apprenticeship in history
and a lifetime of Duty and service I
will defend King Charles and the
institution of the monarchy to the hilt
as a unifying force for good in his
country but as always the devil lurks in
the detail the order of service will say
all those who so desire in the Abbey and
elsewhere say together I swear but I
will pay true allegiance to your majesty
so look so far so good I've got no
problem with those words I can imagine a
lot of people are home actually saying
yeah I can say that I can go along with
that nothing dictatorial about that bit
all those who desire can get involved
all those who don't desire can keep
their big gobs shut or change the
channel or go and watch Celtic but then
the oath concludes with this and to your
heirs and successors according to law so
help me God
and this is where I've got a problem
the king's heirs and successes well they
include a rather unsavory bunch of
characters that many British people
might rather lock in the Tower of London
than pay Allegiance and homage to let's
not forget that Prince Harry the great
Royal traitor is fifth in line to the
throne despite having done more than
anybody living memory with the possible
exception of his wife to trash and
undermine the institution was supposed
to be celebrating
a little further demo list is prince
Andrew eighth in line to the throne who
recently paid a woman he said he'd ever
met 11 million dollars to avoid getting
into court to contest a sex abuse
scandal
his calamitous PR decisions have heaped
Global embarrassment on the Royals now I
believe passionately in the British
Monarchy but I'd rather be garotted
frankly than swear my allegiance to
either Harry or Andrew and I suspect
most British people feel the same in a
severe cost of living crisis and with
polls showing more than half of the
British people don't care about the
coronation especially young people the
idea of pledging allegiance to an
unelected head of state feels like the
wrong answer to a serious question if
King Charles wanted this to be an
inclusive gesture maybe a better place
to start would have been shelving the
oath altogether or doubling down on the
message that he like all harmonics lives
in service to all of us